so let's go back to this so the florida
trial so far we talked about craig
wright fantastic he talked about florida
trial the
trial of the century which you call it
so craig wright is here in miami they're
all talking what's going on wall street
journal there's an article saying
bitcoin creator satoshi nakamoto could
be unmasked at florida trial right with
this going on it's almost a way of
saying you better come out and reveal
yourself right yeah has anybody else
stepped out outside of craig to say i am
the guy or no has there amid this trial
absolutely not like i mentioned phil
wilson there's been a couple of other uh
goofballs that have come out and told
told stories but none of them none of
them make any sense and and craig wright
is the only first of all craig didn't
out himself craig was doxed by wired and
gizmodo magazine in 2015.
at the same time the ato was raiding his
home and a local ato is the australian
irs
and the local media in australia was in
front of his house filming it so
somebody coordinated this basically
takedown of craig wright not realizing
he had left for the uk a few months
earlier and ultimately the reason craig
wright is a public figure at all is 100
not his doing so these magazines said
this man is satoshi nakamoto what can we
learn from him blah blah blah blah so i
think that's an important thing to
remember is that every other satoshi
candidate came out to say well i'm
satoshi and here's why and none of it
made any sense craig denied it for for
quite some time until he was able to get
some of his ducks in a row and then he
would say okay look i'm going to start
to i don't want to just tell everyone
publicly i'm going to bring in some
people privately so he brought in gavin
andreessen who's the guy who uh
satoshi left the keys with um the lead
developer of bitcoin and then he brought
in john mattonus who was the head of the
bitcoin foundation at the time and a
couple other people were offered and as
i understand that somewhere between six
and ten other people have seen and he
said look i wanna i wanna do this right
i wanna show you guys in private i'm
gonna do a a public key private key
signing prove that i control satoshi
nakamoto's assets and that that is that
is one aspect of proving that i'm
satoshi
the problem is is that the second he did
that gavin andreessen had his keys
burned he was removed from bitcoin court
again amid the bitcoin civil war so
these people were like oh wow craig
wright is satoshi
boom gavin and jason you're out kurt i'm
i'm so confused man didn't you say
satoshi actually exists like as a human
being a hundred percent so other people
know him and have interacted with him
correct but there's this but it's on the
internet not in person but it's not in
person i mean is that right i know craig
personally yeah and
so i'm yes
my mind's being blown right is this like
a metaverse thing where craig is satoshi
online
craig so it's it's an alias it's a
pseudonym correct so there is no satoshi
it's a fake name
exactly exactly exactly no that's kind
of like when you write a book and you
don't want to use your name yeah like
gerard michaels i get it yeah it's
dependent i get it but wait so there
actually is no satoshi nagamoto i mean
there are probably people on earth named
no you didn't hear about the story the
guy that's
knocked on his door
and then he's like i'm telling you i'm
not i'm not the founder of bitcoin
so this is a okay
all right gerard you're a joke there's
you're not no way
how do you not know this
no no no no no no no i don't think he is
i'm not i
think i thought this week dude i did not
the the
i thought that there was still debate
whether this guy satoshi nakamoto
actually existed or if it was bs well
they're are you saying the name or the
human
the human being yeah satoshi nagamoto i
think people understand that it's a
human that created this his name wasn't
really satoshi nakamoto i didn't know
that that would have been great i didn't
even know that they could have been i
had no idea that that was that was
settled settled science bro
trust the science man
so
anyways so then so then what happened is
is gavin andreessen and john mattonus
both basically got burned kicked out of
the community you're not real bitcoiners
craig isn't real he's does this guy
gavin claim to have met
satoshi oh yeah he was under deposition
in miami court what did he say he said
you know what there were things that
were goofy about the whole situation but
at the end of the day i i believe that i
met satoshi nakamoto and who did he say
it was it was craig right so craig
wright is is kaiser sose it's
satoshi yes kaiser satoshi nakamoto so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]